في قرار واستراتيجيه قد تغير العالم ومنح
الملايين جرعه امل للتعرف ما يعرف بمرض
العصر السنه المسبب الاول لمعظم الامراض
الحاده والمزمنه منظمه الصحه العالميه
تتده او تتجه لادراج ادويه مكافحه السمنه
لاول مره على قائمه الادويه الاساسيه
للمنظمه فوفقا للمنظمه يتضاعف عدد
المصابين بالسمنه وهناك اكثر من 650 مليون
من البالغين يعانون منها وهو ثلاثه امثال
المعدل لعام
1975 الشهر المقبل ستراجع لجنه من مستشار
منظمه الصحه العالميه طلبات جديده لادراج
الادويه ومن المقرر صدور قائمه محدثه في
سبتمبر فيما تقدم اطباء بطلب ان تتضمن
ادويه السمنه المزيد حول ما هو العلاج
المنتظر مع لم يسيليك لميس
[موسيقى]
السمنه مرض العصر ولا ترتبط بمستوى دخل
الفرد بل تطال الجميع فما العلاج المنتظر
ثلاثه اطباء وباحث في الولايات المتحده
تقدموا بطلب دراسه ادراج ادويه مكافحه
السمنه ويشمل الطلب المكون الفعال في
عقاسه الذي ستنتهي قريبا حقوق استخدامه
الحصري ما سيسمح بانتاج انواع منه اقل
تكلفه
[موسيقى]
ينظم الوزن من خلال اعطاء الاشارات للمخ
بالشبع والماده الفعاله بذلك العقار هي
هرمون
الذي تفرزه الامعاء بصوره طبيعيه بعد
تناول
الوجه لكنه طبيعيا يستمر لمده دقيقتين فقط
اما في الدواء يستمر لثلاثه عشره ساعه
بعد موافقه منظمه الصحه العالميه والمنظمه
الاوروبيه للغذاء والدواء على بدات دور
العلاج لكن بواسطه طبيه وفي حال اعتماد
القرار فسيفتح ذلك المجال لادخال عقاقير
السمنه تحت مظله التامين الصحي وهو ما
سيضمن جودتها والقضاء على عشوائيه انتشار
العقاقير المخالفه وبالتالي تقليل نسبه
الاصابه بالسمنه وامراضها لكن لا يفضل ان
يستخدمه المصاب المصابون بسرطان الغده
الدرقيه اولد عائلاتهم تاريخ مع المرض لذا
ينصح بعمل تحاليل قبل استخدام الدواء